[Musique]
bonsoir les amis bonsoir
depuis que nounours fait un régime
amaigrissant notre nuage devient si
léger qu'il vole deux fois plus vite or
ce n'est pas trop le patron si vous
saviez ce qu'il faut souffrir pour être
beau heureusement pas prenait les
nicolas me comprennent peu
[Musique]
au pom pom pom pom pauvre gros nounours
oh pardon
pauvre nounours
bon soir notre petit nounours
pressoir
enfants
vite une chose
je le tiens
j'ai su frein
l'or
les dépôts
courage nord nous allons chanter une
chanson qui va te faire du bien une
seule entité
pendant ce tronc venir ici mon tour de
porc
ils étaient ils à me taquiner dans un
bol d'air frais la muraille était de
praliné le parquet était de croquer la
chambre à coucher crème de lait l'élu de
biscuits lhériteau dany il
est l'époux ce monsieur jagla de coiffer
de fromage blanc si son chapeau elle te
de galettes de son avis étaient vingt
neuf ans qu'il a tenu qu'à un fil et
chocolat pas de caramel et souliers
demierre
leur fille elle l'appelle charlotte a
fait un mais deux mascottes de très
belles mais dans deux contente d or elle
dû me craquelins je la vois garnir sa
robe de plaisir avec un rouleau de
pâques abricots
[Musique]
le joli prince limonade bien freeze et à
perth abou cissé blocher de marmelade
orné de pommes cuites au four sont
royalement dont deux petits gâteaux et
de résa
s'efforçait tôt respecte
voici qu'elle a fait car au poste
jalousé de mauvaise humeur renversade
d'un coup de sa passe le palais sucré du
bonheur pour le rebâtir d'année à loisir
tenez bon parent du sucre aux infâmes
[Musique]
petit garnement
ce n'était pas du tout la chanson qu'il
me fallait
mais je vous pardonne car elle était
très jolie
au long
cou ni
ennui mon dos ne te fatigue ma mission
littoral
connue de nous
[Musique]
on y va patron en route non bonne source
ce que j'ai faim
je suis courageux mois bonne nuit les
enfants embrasser bien fort vos parents
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette ne
mangeait pas de sucreries est fait de
bouts
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
tous